It's the deadliest bioterror attack in American history on October, the second,
2001 photo editor, Robert Stevens was rushed to hospital suffering,
breathing difficulties. Three days later, he was dead.
The first person to die of anthrax on us soil in 25 years.
But rather than being a freak accident,
Stevens's death was the beginning of a nightmare.
Over the next seven weeks envelopes laced with the deadly bacteria were sent to
politicians and media figures. By the time the attack ended,
five people were dead and another 17 had been second.
But while the deaths had stopped, the attacker was still at large.
It would be another seven years before the FBI found its prime suspect.
Dr. Bruce Ivan's an anthrax researcher at Fort Dietrich.
Ivan's was an expert on the bacteria.
According to the fed to see had the beans to carry out the mailings yet his case
never went to trial ending. Instead, when Ivan's committed suicide,
was he guilty or was he an innocent man, hounded death by the FBI? Well,
today we're going to take a look at the attacks that terrified a nation and the
peculiar life of its prime suspect.
Is he also Leo Tolstoy once wrote happy families are all alike.
Every unhappy family is unhappy in its own way for the unhappy family of
Bruce Edwards. Ivan's that misery, it could be traced back to a single source.
When Ivan's was born on April the 22nd, 1964 in Lebanon, Ohio,
it would be fair to say that his mother was not thrilled.
The third of three boys Ivan's was what?
Some parents term happy accidents.
So there was nothing happy about this accident for Mary Ivan's during her
pregnancy,
Mary repeatedly tried to induce a miscarriage by bouncing down the staircase on
her,
but hoping the thought of the impact might kill her child as Ivan's grew up
and became old enough to understand things. Mary would tell him the story,
making it clear how unwanted he was. Sadly, this casual of cruelty.
Wasn't the worst thing to happen in the Ivan's households.
Outwardly the family was happy. Ivan's his father, the alone to pharmacy.
Mary volunteered with a PTA, but behind closed doors, Randall was a pushover.
Mary subjected to brutal violence.
Ivan's witnessed his mother do things like stab his father with a fork and beat
him with a broom. Once she has him so hard over the head with a skillet,
the family thought she had killed him in such circumstances.
It's perhaps no surprise that Bruce Ivan's was a bit of an odd child ferocious,
and the intelligence Ivan's locked himself away from his parents,
devouring books on science, age 30 14,
he was inviting local girls back to see his homemade gunpowder.
But it wouldn't be a stretch to say that Ivan's has any girlfriends or even
friends later in life.
It claim he was unwanted by everyone that he still harbored feelings of hatred
towards the teenage girls who had rejected him latching on to pretty girls and
then becoming consumed with rage. When they didn't return,
his feelings was a pattern that would repeat throughout Ivan's his life.
There's still no one living in this small town could have known about the
resentment smoldering inside the boy as a teenager,
he was outwardly normal gunpowder aside,
taking part in science and running clubs. When he graduated in 1964,
he easily got a place at the university of Cincinnati pursuing a degree in
microbiology. Yes,
even here away from the mother who belittled him and brutalized his father
Ivan's was still acting strange. At some point,
he was turned down by a girl from the Kappa Kappa gamma sorority.
It was the stars of what Ivan's would later describe as an obsession spans,
Ivan's began to fixate on the campus. He followed news about them obsessively.
It began staking out that campus home.
Eventually he came to believe that the sorority, whereas enemies,
one night Ivan's broken to the campus home inside.
He found the cipher decoding the secret rituals. When Ben's left,
he took the cipher with him.
It was the start of a theme in the young man's life,
punishing women through weird acts of theft from here on out.
These acts were really going to get weirder.
The story of only been as his time at college is really the story of two people.
Bomb led school.
Dr. Ivan's was a successful microbiologist who published multiple papers and his
doctorate and fell in love with and married Diane bench in 1975.
The other one let's call it.
A Bruce was a students haunted by deep depression and a growing feeling of anger
on campus. Bruce would carry a loaded gun. Whenever someone slides at him,
he would take the gun out and shoot it. Objects.
Imagining the faces of his enemies.
He fretted in private that it inherited a demon at birth that whatever darkness
liked within his mother had somehow passed onto him.
It was the mid 1970s when Bruce met Nancy Haywood, married campus,
studying microbiology. At first, he tried to befriend her, but Hey, good.
Considered him playing me nice and rebuffed him.
So Bruce decided to teach her a lesson in 1979,
Haygood was working on a doctoral dissertation.
She recorded all of our results and hypotheses in a single notebook and kept it
locked in the lab. Notebook was the key to Haygoods research.
The cipher to decoding her work.
One day it vanished Hegwood was distraught for days.
She lived in a state of panic until finally an anonymous note arrived telling
her the notebook could be recovered from a public mailbox for the rest of her
life. Haywood would swear.
Bruce had been the one who stole her notes as some sort of revenge.
It wouldn't be until 25 years of passed that Bruce Ivan's sat in an
interrogation room and confirmed her suspicions to the FBI in the 1970s though,
these were only suspicions suspicions that grew every time her car was
vandalized. Every time letters appeared in the local press signed in her name,
saying something outrageous many years later,
Bruce would tell a psychiatrist that Haywood reminded him of his mother had even
made detailed plans. He would confess about murdering her,
but while Bruce was becoming creepier as time cramped by his doctor,
Ivan's personality was becoming successful in 1979.
Ivan's began working on anthrax,
a deadly bacteria known for its great bioweapon of potential naturally found in
soil and Franks can enter the body in multiple ways.
The worst of which is inhalation breathing, anthrax spores,
and your chance of dying is around 80% because of this, it was suspected.
The USSR might try to weaponize it when a deadly Soviet anthrax leak in 1979,
confirmed the suspicions.
The U S became desperate to hire experts on the disease.
One of those experts with Dr. Ivan's in December of 1980,
Ivan's now living in Maryland was hired to work at the United States army
medical research Institute of infectious diseases. Zara at Fort Dietrich,
he would grow purify and test anthrax for a possible vaccine.
It was the perfect placement for a young ambitious docs out,
given a secret security clearance.
Ivan's went on to co and a new vaccine becoming one of the world's leading
anthrax experts. He also settled in at work sticking out,
certainly as an office geek,
he would practice unicycling in the corridors and write silly songs for his
colleagues. His go workers just thought he was harmless,
but this was just one side of the dual personality behind the affable dorky.
Ivan's Bruce still looked still harbored his obsessions and
grudges over the next decade.
Those obsessions would grow into something terrifying.
[Inaudible].
As the 1980s progressed to Bruce's in a life,
begins to revolve around Kappa Kappa gamma up late at night.
He'd leave his home and drive all over the country. Staking out kava houses.
He needs. It told the FBI that had driven to North Carolina and Tennessee,
just so he could look outside sororities and watch the cap of girls on one trip
to West Virginia. He again broke into the house,
stealing the chapters book of ritual.
Bruce was still posing as Nancy Haywood to writing letters,
to newspapers in our name,
defending the practice of hazing and one particularly unpleasant incident.
He sent a copy of Haywood's pro hazing letter to the mother of a boy who died in
a hazing ritual alongside he included a letter in his real name,
common zing on how disgusting Haywood was. But this story,
isn't just a simple as that of a man failing to control his demons.
As the 1990s began,
Ivan's seems to have become increasingly aware that he had problems.
He began seeing counselors taking antidepressants and anti-psychotic drugs in
his sessions.
He would cut loose confessing to one counselor that had procured ammonia,
nitrate,
and bland to make a bomb telling another that he was an avenging angel of death.
But words of this size have got back to his colleagues to them.
He was still Dr. Ivan's red cross volunteer churchgoer and renowned anthrax
expert.
As the millennium Dawn's Ivan's began emailing female lamb technicians telling
them he was having disturbing and violent thoughts in one email to his former
assistant Merlin Scott,
he wrote occasionally I get this tingling that goes down both arms.
At the same time,
I get a bit dizzy and get this unidentifiable metallic taste in my mouth.
Other times it's like, I'm not only sitting at my desk doing work.
I'm also a few feet away watching me do it.
There's nothing like living in both the first person singular and the third
person singular.
What he failed to mention was that he was also the person sending Lynn Scott
crude sexual emails from an anonymous account. Come two thousands.
Bruce Ivan's seems to have been in the grip of a full fledged break-down he
worried that he would not be able to resist the urge to do harm,
but he had a split personality and he couldn't stop thinking of revenge.
On July the 18th.
He even informed a mental health worker that had reformulated a plans, a murder,
Mara Lynn Scott offering how wine laced with cyanide it already mixed it.
He said, when the counselor called the police,
they claimed that no crime had been committed a year later in the summer of 2001
colleagues that started noticing that bruise Ivan's was staying behind in the
lab for long hours after work. He told friends it was peaceful down there,
like being on the surface of Mars shortly after on September the 11th,
2001 hijacked planes slammed into the twin towers in New York,
the Pentagon and to field in rural Pennsylvania killing almost 3000 people.
The following week,
an anonymous batch of letters was quietly dropped into a new jazzy mailbox.
And with that,
the anthrax attacks had begun by the time they were over the U S would have
suffered its worst bioterror instance,
A sign that something was wrong came when Robert Stevens began to suffer chills,
a British born or naturalized us citizen Stevens was a photo editor currently in
the middle of a hiking vacation in North Carolina at first and his wife thought
nothing of his illness. It was September the 29th, 2001.
And all anyone could think about was the smoldering rubble in New York.
The idea that terrorism might involve a plain envelope,
like the one Stevens had come into contact with didn't even cross their minds by
October. The second though, Stevens was in bad shape.
He was sweating red in the face and didn't coherence.
When he was rushed to hospital in Florida,
doctors assumes that had contracted meningitis,
but then an infectious disease specialist because sambal of his spinal fluid
realized it was something much more terrifying.
Steven's his death on October the fifth was the first anthrax death in the U S
in 25 years. Doctors declared it a free Caxton.
Seeing that it likely picked it up while hiking. Although two of Steven's,
his colleagues also fell ill with anthrax.
The public were told not to panic on October the ninth, president George W.
Bush declared. It looks like it's a very isolated incident.
That same day another set of letters were mailed. Four days later,
all hell broke loose on October the 12th and anthrax is that it was opened by an
NBC staffer.
Inside was a note declaring nine 1101. This is next.
Take penicillin. Now death to America, death to Israel. Allah is great.
Three days later, an aid for Senate majority leader,
Tom Dashell was poisoned by another letter. This one, reading nine, 1101.
You cannot stop us. We have this anthrax. You die now. Are you afraid?
Death to America? Death to Israel. A law has great. This last lesson,
paralyzed Congress and the government mail service as panicked,
swept to the media.
Three postal workers who handled the lesser fell ill by October the 21st,
two of them, Thomas Morris and Joseph Caseen would be debt.
But the letter also led to something else on October the 15th,
FBI deposited it at Fort Dietrich for analysis. One day later,
it was handed to Dr. Bruce Ivan's in front of his colleagues.
Ivan's examined the letter, a wet spore specialist.
Ivan's noted the attack spores were dry denies,
capable of spreading through the outlet gas.
He also noted the terrifying purity of the sample. 1 trillion spores,
a gram more than anyone at Fort Dietrich had ever seen away from the lab.
The attacks continued coming so soon after nine 11, the letters left America,
reeling rumors swirled that Al Qaeda were involved or Saddam Hussein.
But then just as the panic was reaching a crescendo,
they stopped no more anthrax letters were deposited after October the ninth.
Although fake anthrax letters would continue to be posted way into 2002.
The crisis was already over on November.
The 21st 94 year old ultimately learned Grande became the last person to die of
the anthrax attacks in total,
the lessors claimed five lives and second 17 more including a seven month old
baby. Not long after that, Bruce Ivan's sent his old flame. Nancy Haywood,
a terrifying photo in its.
He casually held a Petri dish full of anthesis bacteria while not wearing any
protective gear. At that moment. Hagrid later said that awful moments.
I knew it was him.
[Inaudible].
Investigation named [inaudible] gained steam.
The FBI found itself in a worrying position.
This wasn't murder committed with a regular weapon agents needed to learn about
anthrax and fast. So FBI director, Robert Mueller, yup.
That Robert Mueller decided to call them the experts among them was Dr. Bruce
Ivan's. Although Haig would lead to told the FBI of her suspicions,
the feds had ignored her.
Now they were getting Ivan's to explain to them the bacteria he worked with.
Unlike most of the other researchers Ivan's was eager to help. And usually,
so when everyone else the FBI asked about potential suspect swore there's no one
at Fort Dietrich, could've done such a thing. Ivan's happily throughout names,
accusing colleagues and friends. It was all ones,
but it tallied with what the feds were already thinking. Genetic testing.
It traced the Amtrak strain back to a deadly stock known as Ames.
Since the AME strain came from a single cow in Texas, it looks like the attack.
It originated in the U S but thousands of researchers,
how to access to aim stock. So the FBI had also drawn up a profile one,
which suggested a perpetrator working in the biodefense community.
And they were pretty sure that perpetrator was bioterror expert.
Steven Hatfill as the FBI was pursuing Hatfill anthrax expert,
Pat Washam was examining the attack spores.
She noticed that the strain group four distinctive morphs,
if left a culture long enough mutations,
unique to that particular batch motion was ecstatic.
Finding an AME sample that grew the same for morphs,
which mean the attack anthrax had come from the same batch.
All the FBI needed to do was build a database of anthrax from every aims flask,
and then test all of them to see which carried the same mutations.
Whichever had matching spores would belong to the killer brews. Allianz thought.
This is a great idea. He helped draw up the selection criteria,
including a stipulation that a wide sambal be used from each floss,
not just the purist spores. He then hands it over his own sample.
A strain of anthrax named RMR one zero, two, nine,
the FBI tested it and it came back negative for morphs.
Shortly after they raided Steven Hatfill's house on live TV.
It was around this time that Bruce Ivan's did something very strange against
protocol. Bruce started secretly testing his office for anthrax spores.
Decontaminating any potential patch that he found when his colleagues learned of
this all hell broke loose while an unbelieved Bruce was the mailer.
His actions looked very much like those of a man trying to destroy evidence.
There were other weird moments too. On August the eighth,
the mailbox was located in Prince down New Jersey with anthrax spores inside the
place where the first sessions were dropped. No one realized it at the time,
but that mailbox was opposite. Kappa Kappa gamma, his local chapter house.
It wasn't until fall 2003,
that investigators began to look more seriously at Bruce Ivan's around that same
time, power wash them tested a subsample of Ivan's is RMR one zero two,
nine batch. One had long ago sent to another researcher to our shock,
the subsample. It grew identical mutans to the anthrax attack.
Shocking because RMR one zero, two nine had already been tested clear. Yeah,
the subsample. It was so similar. They should have produced the same results.
There was only one answer. Ivan's hadn't handed a sample of his anthrax,
the FBI at all for Bruce Ivan's. This realization would be the beginning of.
Yeah.
In late 2003 federal agents sent Ivan's his philosopher retesting this time,
all form offs grew from us,
but it wasn't until the FBI replaced its lead investigator in 2006,
that it drops its weak case against Steven Hatfield.
They began pursuing Bruce Ivan's by now DNA results from the anthrax mutants
narrowed the list of suspects down to a handful of names. One by one,
those names had been crossed out as suspects provided alibis for September the
eighth, 2001 on October, the ninth, 2001,
the days the letters were mailed at lost only one name remains Bruce Ivan's
couldn't account for his whereabouts on those days.
Additionally we're to details about his life were beginning to seep out and
interviews with federal agents Ivan's would volunteer damaging information
almost like he was trying to destroy his own character. It's old.
The feds about his obsession with Kappa Kappa gamma are about breaking into
their homes. He told them about his harassing behavior towards Nancy Haywood.
If his secret cross-dressing tendencies of his, fetish as 2007,
crawled on the interviews got increasingly aggressive until it was clear.
The mental strain was Gettings Ivan's that's September.
He came to work with a black guy, claiming his wife had hidden it again,
drinking wildly mixing, sleeping drugs with tequila on November.
The first the FBI raided his home. They recovered hate mail to politicians,
pistols and a notes declaring Ivan's would draw first blood
lost, but they never found anthrax spores.
Still the interrogations continued Ivan's was becoming incoherent onto
questioning claiming he wasn't an expert and didn't understand his microbiology.
At one point, he admitted to hacking the emails of a female coworker.
He was obsessed with named Pat no long after some bright spark looked back at
the end.
[inaudible] noticed that many of the AEs and were bolded as if they might be
referring to the nucleotide bases of DNA.
The ones represented by the letters G C a N T lifting out the bolded letters.
They came up with TTT AA, T T a T the amino acids.
These referred to started with the letters P a T it seems the anthrax
Meda had been sending a hidden message.
As the investigation closed in Bruce's behavior got more on nerving.
He told a friend, he could remember multiple times in his life, waking up,
fully dressed the cockies beside him and thinking he had driven somewhere the
previous night and committed some terrible acts online.
He was leaving anonymous comments under videos of women talking about
dismembering them with hatchets on March the 19th.
He was even hospitalized after mixing a ton of pills with booze,
possibly in an attempted suicide. Finally on June the ninth, 2008,
Ivan's went to his group therapy session and declared this.
It bought a Glock and body armor and was going to kill his coworkers.
The next day, he was arrested at Fort Dietrich and placed into psychiatric care.
When the FBI searched his home again, they found several guns,
a Bulletproof vest and hundreds of rounds of ammunition,
but they never get a chance to build the case against him.
On July the 24th Ivan's was released from hospital.
He drove to separate stores and bought huge bottles of Tylenol as each two days
later on the evening of July, the 26th, Dr. Bruce Edward Ivan's downed,
both bottles. You'd have to scroll note beside his bed for his wife.
I have a terrible headache.
I'm going to take some Tylenol and sleep in tomorrow. Please let me sleep,
please. I want, I am on the morning of July, the 27th,
Diane found her husband collapsed in the bathroom of the hospital.
Doctors tried to get her to authorize an emergency liver transplant to save him.
He doesn't want it to be saved. She replied,
Bruce Ivan's died at 10:47 AM on July the 29th, 2008.
Despite the FBI,
since declaring him the sole perpetrator of the anthrax attacks,
significant doubts remain about his guilt as the 2011 national Academy of
sciences report. The claims the FBI overstated the scientific evidence,
linking the attack anthrax to Ivan's a sample there's the 2014 government
accountability office report, which declared the FBI's investigation at times,
lacked precision consistency and adequate standards.
Even from a layman perspective, it's clear that the case had potential holes.
Only an anthrax expert could have pulled this attack off.
And the FBI's anthrax collection relies on those experts submitting their own
samples. It's not too hard to imagine how someone could have gamed that system.
A brilliant psychopath. You could run rings around the entire FBI.
That being said,
the case against Ivan's remains compelling here was a highly intelligent,
deeply troubled man with an expertise in anthrax and a history of stalking,
acts of revenge and darkly, homicidal thoughts.
Is it too difficult to believe that such a man,
one who called himself an avenging angel of death could have quietly snapped,
could have decided he was an untouchable God able to murder.
It will because if that's the case,
then it means the person who pulled off the deadliest biological attack in
American history, it's still out there still living a normal life,
perhaps even still working with anthrax.
The story of the 2001 anthrax attacks may not be fully over,
but what is over is the tale of Bruce Edwards Ivan's and then who may have been
a monster or may have just been a strange, sad and creepy man.
We may not know the truth for sure. But what we can say is that it's clear,
Ivan's suffered at his mother's hands at the hands of the demons in his mind,
whether he responded to that pain by inflicting even worse,
suffering on others is something only he could have told us.
So I'm not going to ask whether you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and as always, thank you for watching.